[Music]
my name's ace I'm a developer programs
engineer here at Google cloud and today
we're going to be talking about how to
keep up with service so design pattern
evolutions for this scalable future so
first I wanted to take a moment to clear
up some confusion on what we mean when
we say service a lot of people think
when you hear service oh that's compute
that things like AWS lambda or Azure
functions or Google Cloud functions but
here at Google we define service a
little bit more broadly than that so in
particular when we're talking about
service we're referring to any platform
that has the following traits say not
just compute so the first of these
traits is plug-and-play auto-scaling
which essentially means that no matter
how many requests you throw at this
thing it'll scale up and scale down
within reason right
the second key trait of serverless
platforms is that they support what's
known as scale to zero behavior right so
this means that essentially if you don't
direct any requests at your service
platform that it will not charge you for
that period so not only do they scale up
and scale down based on load they can
also scale down to the point where they
won't charge you if you don't actually
direct any load at them so this combined
with the typical low to no configuration
experience of many of our service
platforms means that they have a
uniquely low initial cost to get started
on especially if you're developing a
totally new application now last but not
least several US platforms are provider
managed write and what this means is
back in the old days if you wanted to
say a no sequel database right you had
to worry about the infrastructure
underlying that database as well as the
database itself nowadays we can say ok
hey Google give me an O sequel database
I don't want to worry about the
underlying infrastructure I want you to
take care of that right and Google can
say yes that's that's something we can
do that's called cloud firestore cloud
datastore
right so a couple other things I wanted
to cover in terms of high-level caveats
with service and no this is all
background by the way we'll get to the
good stuff in a couple slides so the
first high-level caveat here is that the
way serverless does scalability is sort
of no questions asked I'll get into more
detail about this later
but suffice to say that this can
backfire second the additional
abstraction inherent in this service
model means that it's typically easier
to use and easier to get started with
but it's also less visible and
configurable when it comes to your
deployments versus say the
infrastructure is a service model so a
quick plug for service hosting on GCP I
just want to take the opportunity to
level set everyone in the audience as to
what our products are so off to the left
we have our functions offering google
cloud functions and those essentially
take tiny snippets of code and scale
those to whatever the demand may be
right to the right of that we have App
Engine which takes a plication z--
effectively sets of URL routes that map
to functions to the right of that we
have our newest service product called
cloud run which will allow you to run
containers any service and scalable
manner right now those three are our
sort of true server les options if you
will because they support all three of
those traits to the right of that we
have some service like options such as
cloud run on gke google kubernetes
engine or perhaps even raw gke itself
and those are not quite service because
they don't have all of those traits and
particularly require some degree of
management they are not providing manage
but they have some of those traits so
there's sort of service like in nature
now when you're trying to decide which
one of these products is right for you
of course there is you there could be
reams written about the subject but
generally what you want to do is start
off to the left start off with the most
abstract option and then work your way
right as you find that the abstract
options don't fit your needs for
whatever reason um so enough about the
sort of intro I wanted to take some time
now to go over some common patterns that
we'll see within our patterns ourselves
sort of meta patterns if you will so the
first common trait that we're gonna see
in these patterns today is we're gonna
see lots of asynchronous behavior we're
going to see lots of things like message
queues right second we're gonna see lots
of decomposition so we're going to take
these large tasks decompose them into
many smaller ones but can then third be
distributed amongst a series of many
machines so forth we can have non
soulless components in our service
architectures there are a lot of caveats
this which will kind of touch on in a
later slide but suffice to say yes it
can be done and last but not least I
kinda
alluded to this in the previous slide
self-hosted primitives like databases
are increasingly becoming provider
managed and the so one of that is you is
you the developer is less concerned
about the ops and more concerned about
whatever the platform does right so
you're not thinking of this as oh this
is a no sequel database running on a
Linux instance you just this is a no
sequel database that's it right
so in terms of the benefits of these
patterns the first big benefit is that
distributed architecture gets a lot
easier compared to the pre-service world
so when it comes to things like
kubernetes and orchestration they're
increasingly becoming sort of optional
right if you want that fine-grained
control you can get it through things
like Kay native but if you're like me
you just want to deploy an application
have it scale then you can rely on
things like service to kind of abstract
those that offs that orchestration a way
for you and of course distributed
architecture primitives are no different
they are also transitioning to service
just like the general Cloud primitives
as well and last but not least these
service distributed architectures are
more or less just as scalable as the
old-school distributed architectures so
we don't really lose that much in terms
of scalability by moving to server less
and another thing I wanted to touch on
here is that separation of concerns gets
a little easier right or rather there
are things we can do now with service to
increase our separation of concerns so
oftentimes separation of concerns is
helpful it will make your codebase
easier to work with and to go through
and to maintain not always sometimes it
can backfire this is one of those things
where it might make sense for you it
might not judge based on your particular
facts situation and of course service
and these other new patterns like the
micro service pattern allow us to
achieve higher degrees of separation in
our code bases and now that we've talked
about some of the motivating factors
behind serving us some of why we do it I
wanted to take a moment to touch on sort
of the things that we want to change
going into this service world right so
of course there are some things we want
to change but there are also things we
want to keep right and because we're all
positive people here we're gonna focus
on the things we want to keep first so
the first thing we want to keep is the
presence of this idea of separation of
concerns right
so in particular we probably if you're
coming from the old sort of application
development world you might have heard
of this MVC idea right and essentially
what that is is you take a client facing
application you break it down into three
components you have your models your
views and your controllers now for those
of you who are not familiar with this
model no pun intended basically what
happens is your models are your database
schema your views are your front-end and
then your controllers are essentially
your business logic right now of course
this was a step in the right direction
but for reasons we'll get into later we
can actually do better than this pattern
another thing that we want to keep is
how we do distributed architecture so we
knew back then that it could give us
less coupling and higher throughput
compared to non distributed
architectures and we also knew that it
was one of the few ways to truly scale
our application simply because vertical
scaling can only work up to a point more
or less given technological restrictions
and after that our only other option is
horizontal scaling which is by
definition a distributed system right
the last thing I wanted to touch on here
is how we do things in the front end you
might be familiar with this idea of
thick clients basically you take all
your business logic and instead of
putting it on the back end you kind of
move most of it towards the front end
right now it turns out that service
allows us to create uniquely lightweight
backends which can be a natural fit for
things like thick clients and single
page apps so as I said service backends
naturally fit these existing front-end
techniques so in terms of the things
that we do want to change the things
that we might want to do differently
when we move the service the first is
client facing app patterns and app
design patterns have improved a little
bit since right like I said it turns out
we can use other patterns to achieve a
greater degree of separation concerns
than we can with the the
model-view-controller approach also
distributed systems back then we're
notably harder to implement right
principally you had to worry about offs
and/or orchestration you probably had to
worry about things like kubernetes or
unmanaged components within your
distributed system right now also
another thing was back then there were
no real tools for doing lightweight
event processing right
or excuse me light weight yet flexible
event processing the best you could do
with something like if this than that
right which is good as long as you as
long as it's WYSIWYG approach contains
whatever you're trying to get done but
the second that it doesn't you more or
less
can't just write a code on top of
something like that right so adding your
own custom logic like I said meant
writing your entire application from
scratch so that begs the question well
what does serverless change what does
service bring to the table that is
inherently different than this pre
service world so the first thing to bear
in mind is that service is more capital
e evolutionary than capital our
revolutionary right so the service way
naturally is more of an evolution of old
approaches than a completely new
approach in a in and of itself
distributed systems the way those work
is you're starting to see increasingly
serverless versions of core distributed
systems primitives so things like caches
message queues so on and so forth and
you're starting to see the higher-level
architectural principles actually not
change are they more or less stay the
same when you move from this non
serverless distributed architecture to
the service variant right and as a
hands-on demo of what this looks like so
let's say we have a pretty canonical
distributed system here it just kind of
accepts a stream of imagery sized
requests uses a message queue to load
balance those across some set of compute
units and those compute units will then
resize those images and do something
with them whether it's returning them
back or storing them in some sort of
storage or something like that right now
this is the old-school way of doing
things we had our message queue
presumably running on some sort of
infrastructure as a service so this
might be like rabbitmq or whatever and
then that was load balancing amongst a
bunch of compute units right which in
this case are raw compute engine VMs now
the downside of this is we have to still
worry about that ops component right yes
it works yes it's scalable but we still
have to worry about the the GCE or gke
ops workload so if we move the service
version of this of course we have less
of that ops concern but the beauty of
this is that we can kind of
transliterate these non service
components over here pretty much just to
service components off the bat right
we're not even saying ok well we have to
do anything different with our message
queue or we have to do anything
different use some sort of different
version of compute all we're doing is
we're taking a non service component
swapping it out for a server
component and once we make that change
making any required code changes to mesh
the two together right and for reference
the products on the right here
essentially what we're doing is we're
taking that again that message queue
that is running on infrastructure
swapping it out with its service
alternative which is something like
Google cloud pub/sub we're taking the
server full compute and swapping it out
with service compute which in this case
is Claud functions so in terms of what
else is new
so web front-end ideas and I kind of
already touched on this also already fit
this service world quite well so notably
things like HTML templating and Static
file hosting haven't really changed CD
ends whatnot they're all still relevant
but thick clients is really where
service kind of comes into its own right
the idea of a thick client a thick
front-end is not new but once you pair
that with the thin backends afforded by
service this means you can get really
good meshing between your front end and
your back end so as an example of how
this works sort of in the real world or
with a contrived problem admittedly oh
so let's say we have this example pet
store here right so there are a couple
different actions that the users can
take those are all sort of our views on
the front end the list by cart and pay
URLs and then we're backing this with a
monolith running on gke for its sort of
back in compute and then we have a bunch
of primitives or components off to the
right here so you'll see there that the
first component in that list of
primitives is a sequel database
right now if you're thinking okay well I
want to scale this thing that sequel
database can scale up to a point but I'm
not going to be able to horizontally
scale that right I'm eventually gonna
hit a bottom like and I'm gonna have to
get rid of that sequel database right
you might think okay well I can just
migrate that that sequel database to a
no sequel alternative and boom I'll have
horizontal scalability right and that is
correct right this application as it is
if you architect it in the right way is
horizontally scalable it will scale up
and scale down to meet demand but it's
not entirely serviced you still have to
worry about things like orchestration
and ops right because you have your sort
of server full computer you have your
server full primitives but if you want
to sort of abstract that office workload
away if you want to start moving towards
service what you can do is say okay Wow
start with the primitives right and
again like we did in the previous
example we can transliterate those
primitives not even translate
transliterate those primitives from from
their server full options to their
server less options right so we might
look at this and say well we have a no
sequel database right and we have a log
service and those are server fold those
are running on some sort of
infrastructure now what is a service log
Service write something like stackdriver
logging what is a service no sequel
database something like cloud datastore
a cloud fire store right so it turns out
if we just kind of do that
transliteration and then update our code
accordingly we can say okay boom we've
got our primitives running on service
we've more or less reduced our office
workload by migrating everything right
but there's still the elephant in the
room or rather the elephant and the
architecture here which is that monolith
in the middle right so if you wanted to
do a simple well not so simple if you
wanted to do the easiest possible lift
and shift to get on the server list you
might say well maybe I want to put that
on some sort of sort of raw server let's
compute option like cloud run or maybe
maybe App Engine right cloud run would
probably be ideal if you wanted the
least effort lift and shift for
something like a gke cluster right but
you're in this situation where you're
dealing with the thick client you say
okay well maybe we should take the time
to react detect this so we can really
take advantage of not only server less
but the advantages afforded to us by
this thick client on the front end right
so what you can do is say well if we're
gonna go the extra mile let's go ahead
and migrate this to something like cloud
functions some sort of service compute
option and by doing that not only do we
get the the benefits of service in terms
of ops and scalability but we build an
architecture that is better suited to
this idea of the thick client front-end
right as opposed to having this massive
back-end and this massive front-end
where there's also all sorts of logic
duplication all sorts of additional
maintenance all sorts of bad things that
you're doing on both for really no good
reason right
so in terms of what else is new what's
changed a little bit in terms of
abstraction is back then we only really
had one option and that was
infrastructure so that meant that we had
more work but we also had more control
and visibility of our over our
deployments right nowadays the beauty of
serve
is that it strictly gives us additional
options right so in terms of service
options they give it to us a lower
getting started point a lower minimum in
terms of the work that we have to do but
if we want that additional control and
additional visibility we can still say
hey service isn't right for me I want
these things so I'm gonna go off you
know towards the infrastructure side of
things right and as I mentioned earlier
with the default cost model it has
changed a little bit for non service
platforms it used to be we would set a
billing limit and then we would fail at
that point right so once we hit that
quota we basically serve the user or a
quota exceeded error or something like
that and the beauty of that is if we got
a sudden deluge of requests that we
didn't want to fulfill say it was a
denial service attack or bug in our code
then this is the right approach and we
wouldn't be charged fulfilling requests
that we didn't fulfill right now it is
the approachment service is essentially
scale now pay later
right now this approach works well when
you get a sudden deluge of legitimate
requests say for example your marketing
team knocks it out of the park and you
come into work next day and you know you
pick up your copy of you know your
favorite national newspaper and your app
is right there on the front page right
and suddenly everyone in the country or
everyone across the world is trying your
application and your user base has gone
up by like 10 or 50 X or whatever in
that sort of situation you want to make
sure that your applications can scale up
to handle that demand rather than
serving all of your you know new users a
bunch of quota exceeded errors right
because that leaves a very bad
impression as to your application so the
one thing I do want to note is that this
is a these are defaults they can be
changed so if you are in the situation
where you're using non service but you
want it to you know sort of have that
unrestricted scaling capability you can
do that if you're also in a situation
where you want to use service but you
want to restrict its ability to scale
that is something you can do as well so
now I'm going to touch on the good stuff
the actual design patterns that we're
going to be using in this service
environment so first of all a quick
intro into the things that have changed
so the first design pattern that we do
a little bit differently is how we do
busy weight right so back in the old
days we used to be able to rely on
things like call backs or blocking calls
and kind of wait around for long running
tasks to complete right
nowadays we try to rely more on message
passing and things like call backs with
their own separate endpoints which I'll
show in the next slide so in terms of
what this looks like it with a hands-on
example the old-school way of doing
things might be to say ok well we're
gonna do some effectively instantaneous
operation right like getting a user ID
then we're going to kick off some slow
long-running external operation and then
we're gonna wait we're gonna kind of
walk around stage take a sip of our
coffee
you know twiddle our thumbs whatever go
to the bathroom and then once that
operation is done now bear in mind while
we're waiting this operation we still
have that cloud functions instance
running that is still reserved that is
still costing us compute time now that
that operation is done then we write the
result to the database now there are two
big problems with this one the first
thing is cloud functions has a nine
minute timeout right at most so if this
slow external operation takes longer
than nine minutes well will actually end
up happening is something like that that
last line of code will not execute your
function will throw a timeout error and
it will cease s execution now the second
problem is that your even if this
operation does complete even if it's a
takes six or seven minutes you're still
paying for seven minutes worth of
compute where you're not really doing
anything during those seven minutes
right you're just kind of sitting around
waiting for this operation to complete
so of course that was then and this begs
the question well how can we do this in
a better way so it turns out we can do
it in a better way ah so what we want to
do is essentially take all of our
instant operations are synchronous
operations and put them in one function
right and then we want to take that slow
external operation and turn it into some
sort of asynchronous alternative right
now there are a couple ways we can do
this some operations such as those with
the data loss prevention API give us the
ability to pass in a pub subtopic that
will then be notified when that
operation is complete right so we
essentially say hey slow external
operation when you're done can you
publish a ping to this topic my topic
and
slow external operations yeah sure I can
do that and I can also include this ID
as metadata if you want me to so once we
do that we can say okay great I'm gonna
go to sleep now this cloud function is
going to go to sleep now after kicking
off this external operation and it
doesn't matter how long that external
operation takes once it's done that
pub/sub message will be fired and it
will trigger the second cloud function
that writes this result to the database
right and again it doesn't in this case
this solves both of those two problems
right it solves the timeout problem
because once that slow external
operation is kicked off this cloud
function can exit and say I don't have
to do anything anymore right if it takes
you know all of 100 milliseconds to kick
that operation off then you're being
charged for 100 milliseconds plus
whatever it cost to get the user ID
you're not being charged for the amount
of time that the operation is running
and second even if that operation takes
an hour right you don't have to worry
about that time out because this cloud
function is only running for you know
however long it needs to get that ID and
kick off the operation not actually wait
for the operation to complete so the
next pattern I want to touch on is how
we do session affinity right and
basically the idea with this is back
then we could rely on session affinity
which essentially means that if we send
a if a user sends like say 10 requests
that those 10 requests will all go to
the same machine right you might be
using a distributed architecture you
might have you know thousands of
machines across your entire application
but each user will always go to the same
machine more or less right now nowadays
with service that's increasingly not
available right so a users requests may
hit different machines and this affects
how we're going to store State through
those user requests right the second
thing I wanted to touch on here is
explicitly machine State right not just
user state but the state of the machines
themselves so back then we could also
rely on things like persistent machines
we could rely on saying okay I want to
save this to disk or I want to save this
to RAM and I can trust that when the
user comes back that it'll still be
there right nowadays we're increasingly
moving to ephemeral architectures right
so there are no guarantees in terms of
where
the user is going to land they might
make ten different requests or excuse me
they might make ten different requests
and the machine could start up and shut
down and start up and shut down ten
different times right even if they even
if you have such an affinity even if it
goes to the same machine every time it
doesn't really matter because if that
machine was provisioned and D
provisioned and provisioned and D
provisioned then those d provisioning
can wipe state from that machine right
and of course going back to session and
affinity a little bit that is doubly a
problem because even if you have those
persistent machines it doesn't really
matter if the user could hit you know
ten different machines across ten
different requests so the solution to
both of these problems is you're going
to want to persist your data outside of
your actual compute right so once that
request is done maybe you send it off to
some sort of cache or you send it off to
some sort of cloud data store or
something like that the idea is you're
not relying on any state within the
service compute option itself because
that state is essentially ephemeral so a
couple more things I wanted to touch on
in terms of design patterns so first how
we do retries has changed a little bit
right so we're trial bull operations it
used to be we kind of had to have our
own doctor node if you will that would
say okay this operation failed
I'm gonna go retry that and I'm gonna
keep her trying this operation until it
succeeds increasingly that is being
offloaded to server less alternatives
such as service message queues so we can
use things like pub/sub and call tasks
as our sort of artificial doctor nodes
where they will say okay I'm going to
retry this operation for example for
pub/sub I'm gonna try this operation
until you actually acknowledge receiving
my message right and if your operation
fails you simply say okay I'm not gonna
acknowledge that pub/sub message and it
will automatically send me another copy
that message when it's ready right now
another thing that changes I kind of
alluded to this and some of the previous
slides but it's how we can take
advantage of separation of concerns
right so it used to be back then we
would rely on something like the MVC
approach the Model View controller model
nowadays we can take advantage of what's
known as the Micra service pattern right
and this is a little bit of a buzzword
but which we'll explain in the next
slide but essentially what it means is
that we
can achieve like I said that greater
separation of concerns so in terms of
what this micro service term actually
means what we're talking about here is
the idea that apps are collections of
small services right
um so each service has its own narrowly
scoped purpose as well as its own
codebase now how you store these code
bases is highly dependent on your
particular situation but some common
patterns that we've seen you might say
okay well I want to put all of my code
from my application in one giant version
control repo and then have a bunch of
directories each directory corresponding
to a micro service right you might also
say in your situation maybe it's easier
to set up CI CD in this manner
continuous integration and deployment
you might say okay I want to put each of
these services in its own repo right
whatever situation makes sense for you
that's that's what you should do there
is no one right answer here now some of
the benefits of this micro service
pattern versus the MVC approach first of
all we get per service control of a
bunch of different things namely things
like scaling permissions and access
control we also get the enforcement of
good API design right now this can be a
double-edged sword depending on your
situation if you're working on something
that's just a quick hack a quick
prototype you probably don't want
something like this you may not want the
micro service pattern but if you're
working on a team with dozens or
hundreds of people and you're trying to
build something that is going to last
for years then having that consistent
API enforcement that consistent software
engineering practice can actually be
really helpful in terms of the longevity
of those larger code bases and last but
not least this is one of the key
benefits of us of micro services they
give us this language and stack
independence right so for example if you
wanted to write an application and there
were five micro services you could write
it with five different stacks five
different languages you could say I want
to write these two in Java I want to
write this one in C++ I want to write
that one in c-sharp
and I want to write that one in node and
as long as they have a common
communication protocol such as JSON over
HTTP or protobuf or something like that
then you're good right as long as they
can talk to each other and they know
each other's API
then you can do whatever whatever you
want in terms of tech stack right so um
as an example of how this works here's
our canonical pet store again so this is
the MVC approach right we have our views
on the Left which again are our front
ends we have our controllers in the
middle which is our business logic and
then we have our models on the right now
if you look at this you'll notice that
there's a lot of complexity going on
between the checkout method and all
these various models in fact that's
connecting to the user method the pay
method and the user cart or the user
model excuse me the pay method model and
the user cart model as well so of course
that complexity means it's very hard for
us to separate those two components
which kind of makes us sad right we
can't exactly just go say oh I just want
to reuse checkout over here we have to
kind of yank all those models out of it
so in terms of what this looks in like
in the micro service as app world you
might even glance at this and say wow
this is crazy how is this any simpler
than that MVC approach there's so much
stuff going on here but the reality is
when you look at if you look at it in
the right way you'll start to see ok
well the separation of concerns looks
something like this right so you have
your pet service which has its own
database has its own back-end logic and
all it cares about are three API methods
right list pets add pet and remove pet
so if it's its own sort of create read
update delete information storage
service the beauty of this is you can
change whatever internal details of the
pet service that you want to without
having to worry about the rest of the
services right the only time you need to
worry about the other services is when
you're changing the external facing
api's now of course because this is a
micro service architecture the current
service same thing right you can change
you could say ok it's running on Java
I want to code it in Python right it's
running on Python I want to move it to
c-sharp whatever as long as that API
interface remains the same you can
change essentially whatever you want
and of course the pay service is no
different it's also isolated now note
that this does call out to those other
micro services so you would have to
update it if those micro service has
changed but again the actual sort of
inner back-end logic here is totally
isolated from what happens elsewhere
so in terms of bridging the gap between
these two worlds between the the
pre-service world and the service world
we live in today the first thing you're
going to want to be aware of is that
there's among many different problems
there's one really big one right and
that is this idea of non scalable or not
quite service parts if you have parts
that are scalable and but not serviced
they're a little easier to deal with
but non-scalable parts mean that you
have to do things a little bit
differently so notably what you're going
to want to do is treat this as
essentially what academics would call a
producer-consumer problem right which
means you have a producer you have
something producing tasks and then you
have a consumer that is consuming those
tasks now your producer might be serving
as your producer might be scalable but
if your consumer is not you want to make
sure you don't overload your consumer
with so many requests that it buckles
under the pressure so what you can do is
use pub/sub or cloud tasks or some sort
of surveillance message queue as a task
buffer right and that buffer will kind
of throttle how many tasks are coming
out within a given amount of time or
within a given set of parameters and
ensure that your downstream service that
can only handle say X tasks a minute or
extracts per whatever period or s X tax
tasks excuse me at once does not get
overloaded with so many tasks that it
buckles under the pressure and if you
need additional sort of fine-tuned logic
on top of this you can use things like
App Engine or cloud functions to give
you that additional consumer logic right
now this fine-tune logic might be that
say pub/sub and cloud tasks don't
support exactly the throttling policies
you want so then you have to implement
them in some sort of service compute
option which because that service can
handle that volume of requests or it
might be that you want to take those
requests you want to perform some
modification to them and only then do
you want to send them to your downstream
service right regardless of which one of
those situations you're and having this
additional layer of service compute can
help you achieve that
so some rules of thumb when it comes to
migrating to service note of course this
is a very very very complex topic if
you're seriously if you or your company
are seriously considering sort of
undertaking this journey what I
recommend is you check out the talk by
my colleagues martin omander
and Adam Ross serverless - OH - from
monolith to microservices they will take
you through this in a lot more detail
than I'm about to now but essentially
what you want to remember first of all
service is not magic right things like
data dependencies things like slow i/o
things like application security these
still exists they are still concerned
service it's helpful but it does not
it's not a panacea it does not solve
everything so the second thing when
you're doing this migration you
generally speaking want to do it slowly
and piece by piece because if things
break it's easier to isolate what the
cause of that breakage was if you kind
of go slow and don't don't rush it
through right now you also don't want to
go all or nothing in terms of old
approaches right like I said sort of
less is more capital e evolutionary than
capital R revolutionary so you want to
take advantage of this you want to take
advantage of the sort of prior art that
exists in this old world that will
enable you to leverage that to build
your new service architecture you don't
want to say reinvent the wheel so to
speak and last but not least when it
comes to making your app totally
serverless this will give you a slight
boost because at that point you won't
have to worry about things like offs
anymore and more or less you'll have a
much more scalable app if if you're
dealing with non scalable components but
the thing to bear in mind is this is not
a reason to migrate your application all
at once the benefit from going totally
service is totally outweighed by the
costs that may be imposed by migrating
your app all at once if anything goes
wrong
so definitely despite this this is the
reason to sort of see it through but
it's not a reason to rush that migration
process though so um now that we've
touched on some of the things that have
changed some of the 0 to 1 changes in
terms of service I wanted to take a
moment to talk about the the capital our
revolutionary aspect of cyrillus right
so these are new patterns that we can
take advantage of that we're not really
available to us before service and
things like functions as the service
showed up so the first of these patterns
is how we do event processing and
automation right so it used to be that
if we wanted lightweight deployments we
had to use some sort of well to be
honest they didn't exist right the best
we could do is use infrastructure which
was kind of had
wait even if we said okay here's this
ten lines of code every time I get a
gmail message run this code right
that would mean setting up a whole
entire application for those ten lines
of code and it just really wasn't worth
it in terms of the time we'd save by
writing all this automation right
nowadays what we can do is increasingly
rely on just individual functions single
functions and we can say hey all I have
to do if I want to run this ten lines of
code is write the ten lines of code and
stick it up on cloud functions right I
don't have to worry about okay I wrote
the 10 lines of code now I have to set
up say you know infrastructure I have to
set up maybe a lamp stack or something
like that another thing I want to touch
on here is the ubiquity of events right
so things like web hooks and pub/sub are
common today but they're becoming
increasingly common in the future right
now web hooks are common with external
platforms what you also see with pub/sub
is that you can access a lot of events
through things like stackdriver logging
right so as we mentioned previously in
that busy wait slide not all operations
will have access to a pub sub
notification when they're complete but a
lot of operations will instead notify
logged a stack driver when that
operation is finished so that's
something where you can say okay well
I'm going to take that stack driver
notification I'm gonna export that
sector logging notification to pub sub
and then pub sub is going to use that to
trigger a cloud function right so
essentially and there's a tutorial on
this on our on our site if you go to
cloud.google.com slash function and
slash Doc's this is a tutorial that
walks you through how to trigger a cloud
function in response to a stack driver
notification so the TLDR here is not
only is web hooks or not only our web
hooks and pubs like becoming increasing
in common but various other services
like stack driver are also starting to
feed into pub sub that can essentially
be converted into pub sub notifications
and of course G suite is no different so
G suite integration is also becoming
easier through things like REST API s
and this type of thing allows you to
take advantage of line of business
automation and making your day-to-day
workflow more efficient using using
various forms of code right for those of
you that have seen any of the like
automation charts out there there's a
particularly famous one from a certain
webcomic
but essentially the way that works is
you have you have a certain amount of
time that you save by doing that
automation right like maybe you run this
task you know X times a day or X times a
week it takes Y amount of time and it
would take you Z amount of time to
automate it right and depending on those
parameters it's either worth it or not
worth it to automate that task now where
this serverless pattern becomes really
useful is if you want to make those
sorts of lightweight G sweet automations
like I said line-of-business automations
you can do that right because serverless
decreases that Z for you it decreases
the amount of time that it would take to
set up an automation for a given task
now rapid prototyping is another thing
that changes a little bit notably a
rapid prototyping and a service world
means that serverless is great for
gluing together disparate api's right so
let's say you have a constellation of
really powerful api's that do really
interesting things then you can quickly
stitch them together using things like
cloud functions and our other service
offerings and use that to create easily
scaled apps right which is great because
if you build something that is you know
the next best thing but you don't know
it yet and you tell your friends and
suddenly you know you wake up tomorrow
morning and it's on you know like I said
it's on a national newspaper or
something because it's the best thing
since sliced bread then you want to make
sure you can handle that scaling right
and that's why a service is great for
that kind of workload now a corollary
that I wanted to touch on real quickly
is also how we do market testing right
so if you want to build something where
you're not sure what the addressable
market for it is service is great
because it will give you first of all a
typically smaller upfront cost than non
service platforms right now this is
Intuit this reduced cost takes place in
two ways the first is the compute cost
is pay-as-you-go so it's very easy to
say okay well if I don't use as much
compute as I think I'll need to then I
don't have to commit to a certain amount
of compute I can just pay as I go if you
underestimate how many users you're
going to get then you can say okay well
I didn't have to pay for 10,000 users
worth of compute I can just pay for you
know whatever 1,000 however many users I
actually get right so you're not on the
hook for that now if you're in that
opposite situation where you think
you're
gets a 10,000 users and you end up
getting a hundred-thousand or you know a
million right the scalability inherent
and serverless
means that apps can handle those sudden
explosions in popularity now of course
you have to design your application in
the right way which is why we're
covering design patterns here but if you
do that then server lists can generally
say oh I understand you told me that we
were gonna get you know a thousand users
but maybe we got 10,000 or 100,000 no
biggie don't worry about I can scale
right so as far as a quick recap of
everything we cover today the first
thing to bear in mind is that service is
more capital e evolutionary than capital
our revolutionary right so many service
patterns are essentially updated
versions of older patterns right and
that being said service does fit neatly
within a lot of these existing patterns
so things like micro service use can
help us increase our separation of
concerns which can make our code easier
to maintain and reuse also these service
backends are uniquely a good fit or a
uniquely good fit excuse me for thick
client front ends right if most of our
business logic is on the front end then
we can take advantage of this to get a
uniquely lightweight back-end and of
course how we persist state has kind of
changed when we're dealing with service
compute we persist that state outside of
compute and of course caching and things
like caching and persisting your data
stores may become increasingly important
now one more slide that I wanted to
recap on so this asynchronous mindset is
of course key and the service
environment right so we're starting to
see things like decomposition take hold
where we take all these tasks we
decompose them and then wrap those
subtasks around using various messaging
strategies such as pub/sub cloud tasks
and HTTP typically you'll see pops up in
cloud tasks HTTP is less common but it
does happen in some cases now of course
the benefits of this approach you get
generally speaking a better throughput
and scaling performance in your
application you also get reduced busy
weight cost if you're dealing with
long-running operations right and as I
said not all of those operations will
conform to that exact pub/sub model
sometimes you have to rely on things
like stack driver or web hooks or
whatever but the same logic applies
now if you're dealing with flow control
because you have to do some throttling
or retry logic or something like that
perhaps you have some sort of non
scalable component somewhere in your
architecture or some retry herbal
function that's where you're going to
want to use something like pub/sub and
if you need that compute you're gonna
use something like App Engine cloud
functions you may not need that compute
in which case you might just use pub/sub
you might just use cloud tasks something
like that then of course service opens
up a bunch of new possibilities like I
said it's it's more evolutionary capital
e evolutionary than capital R
revolutionary but it does have its
capital R Revolutionary aspects right so
first of all how we do lightweight event
processing is increasingly being
modernized through things like functions
as a service and second service enables
us to do rapid prototyping and rapid
scaling at the same time they are no
longer mutually exclusive we don't have
to say we want this to scale rapidly so
we have to set up a bunch of
orchestration and do a bunch of
configuration to get that scalability we
can just build our application more or
less throw it on server less and as long
as we design our app in the right way it
will just automatically scale up and
scale down with whatever workload we
throw at it so that's it for me
if you have any questions please do
reach out to me via email at fast at
Google comm thats the word fast with two
A's or functions as a service my team
and I couldn't figure out what the T
stood for it just sounded nice and then
of course you can hit me up on Twitter
at server loss as well
[Music]